quelque part à l'abri des regards
tension sur fond de partisanerie au delà
des grands débats et des échanges
musclés un petit enjeu qui dérange au
quotidien c'est tellement vite que c est
désolant fait de la façon dont cet effet
mais qu'est ce qui provoque cet
emportement
c'est un endroit secret au parlement nos
caméras n'y ont pas accès
l'antichambre de l'opposition cette
pièce derrière les rideaux des communes
là où les députés reprennent leur
souffle
entre les débats nourriture fauteuils
tables et ordinateurs réservé aux élus
du npd et des conservateurs les
bloquistes et la chef du parti vert n'y
ont pas droit
ils sont confinés au vestiaire parce que
leur parti n'est pas reconnu on va
désigner le vestiaire
pour se tenir pour tous ont fait deux
réunions en plus pour manger il ya un
serrage et servi un petit lunch le
métier parce qu'on arrête potier gel at
il dit alors on doit prendre nos
assiettes c'est un élément joue dans le
vestiaire mais l'on nous ait consenti
quelques chaises hautes espérances près
de la fin de mur des manteaux il ya un
siège petit petit câble sièges et il ya
ici un couloir
elizabeth may est une habituée du
vestiaire en 2011
hélas eu droit à une chaise près de la
penderie cadeau du chef intérimaire du
parti libéral de l'époque bob rae il m'a
donné une pièce je suis ravie avec mon
chef parce que c'est vraiment difficile
de travailler sans le droit de siéger
pour manger mais le chef du bloc
québécois lui ne la trouve pas drôle
parce qu'on n'est pas d'où l'on n'a pas
besoin d'aller s'asseoir aux tables
- et puis si on était dans une garderie
de l'éducatrice dirait fed a placé des
petites amies dont ils vont déranger que
toi alors qu'elle rendait dans un
parlement pour nécessaire c'est presque
un siècle c'est désolant
mais les amis de l'opposition n'ont pas
l'intention de céder ressenti mr k
tradition c'est la tradition il faut au
moins 12 députés pour se négocier une
place
on connaît les règlements quand on se
présente comme 6 empreinte
mais quand on n'a pas de temps à perdre
et qu'ils ont choisi nous n pdci on
offre accès à un guichet joie des tables
ça nous enlève de l'espace elle nous
voilà qui libéreront les conservateurs
aussi fassent leurs efforts pour dégager
plus de place dans le passé de prises de
position du bloc toujours été de ne pas
changer avec consulter les autres partis
qui ont été impliqués la dispute du
vestiaire est le symbole des
frustrations que vivent les partis qui
ne sont pas officiellement reconnu le
bloc est à deux députés d'un plus grand
budget et d'une participation plus
importante aux activités du parlement
le bloc a l'intention de déposer une
motion pour changer la définition de
partis reconnus il voudrait au moins un
budget de recherche et un droit de
parole proportionnel à son nombre de
députés la chef du parti vert est
d'accord c'est une question d'équité
quoi tel est primordial pour moi que
chaque piquet a les mêmes droits que
tous les autres pépites et parce que les
citoyens de ma circonscription a le même
doigt comme citoyen que tous les autres
citoyens du canada
certaines écoles du parti
avant de reconnaître les parties quoi ce
mandat ne serait pas mais la partie un
peu descendre le trait de caractère à ce
qu'on soit reconnu il serait étonnant
que le gouvernement libéral change les
règles faveur des bloquistes
au mieux il fera des accommodements à la
pièce mais vu la position du npd et des
conservateurs les petits partis ne sont
pas sortis du vestiaire